my talk of the table topic is about that
famous muscle car that king of cool
Steve McQueen drove in a classic 1968
will be Bullitt take a look this iconic
scene gave birth to the modern-day car
chase scene the 1968 Mustang GT became a
legend especially after it disappeared
for decades now it's resurfaced and is
up for auction today the Mustang is
expected to go for millions mark
Strassmann is in Kissimmee Florida with
the car and it's story mark I am
especially jealous today take us for a
ride Anthony I know you're a car guy and
you're going to appreciate this here it
is the Bullitt Mustang behind protective
glass this is an American icon on four
wheels we're gonna pop inside the glass
box in a second but first listen to the
car story it has taken one American
family on the ride of a lifetime in this
sea of supercars only one revs star
power not these portions of Ferraris not
this million dollar McLaren senna nope
this is the star car a rusted dented
Highland green 1968 Ford Mustang GT
Fastback
it's worth a fortune this is the holy
grail of muscle cars it's the Holy Grail
Mustangs like Dana Meachem owns the
world's leading option house for
collector cars this'll pretty much be
the first American muscle car to sell
his art it's gonna sell pop culture
here's why the movie Bullitt and this
ten minute thrill ride on the streets
and hills of San Francisco it reinvented
chase scenes for Hollywood
and Mustang Steve McQueen and his
classic pony car the epitome of
old-school cool even faster than
McQueen's car its disappearance after
the movie collectors have chased it ever
since it was never lost I mean was
always in the garage
Shawn Kiernan's father bought the
Mustang in 1974 it's kind of the
Craigslist of the day was the rodent
track you know then and found a 68
fastback Mustang found it in this back
page at McQueen's Bullitt Mustang best
offer Robert Kiernan paid $3,500 he's
the only one that showed up paid for it
took off and ended up in the driveway
Robbie Kiernan is Shawn's mother she
drove the car to her job every day as a
third grade teacher in New Jersey back
and forth to school yeah it was just you
know loud and have to drive through the
center of Madison and they all knew the
car here she comes
when you were driving a multi-million
dollar car it was to me a used bar in
1977 McQueen tracked down the Kiernan's
he wanted to buy what he called my
Mustang they never responded in 1980 its
clutch died the car was parked in a barn
for 35 years the car sat on jack stands
and the world kind of evolved around it
after his father died in 2014 Shawn a 38
year old admitted car not completely
restored it himself
98% original parts
and showed it to us in 2018 it still had
the camera mounts a huge hole cut in the
trunk for the smoke machine and the prey
of its 390 big-block engine for movie
goers and car lovers of a certain age
this was a joyride
over the last year and a half Kiernan
has shown off the car around the world
he swore he had never sell it because he
could still see his father inside it but
here we are building and unveiling the
car has been extremely therapeutic the
card has become bigger than my life and
yeah I want to go home and I think the
car deserves it another good home
will you miss it absolutely I'll miss it
most because of the blood sweat and
tears I've had with her for the past
five years the funny thing about that is
I think that she'll miss me too
ordinarily this Mustang in this
condition would solve for about $25,000
but with the movie McQueen and a
mystique this car at auction this
afternoon should sell for between 2 and
5 million dollars that's a pretty fair
return on a $3,500 investment
Anthony yeah but I love long said it's
just a used car most iconic used car and
hit movie history Marc thank you very
much Steve McQueen had written I don't
know I love it they didn't even answer
him I would have came but they did give
it a very good home what a great story
what a great history I love Mustangs my
mom bought a Mustang in 1988 she broke
up with my dad who deserved to be broken
up with okay purple red Mustang
convertible
a hundred straight away here in the
Everglades you know your dad's going
thanks son that car is worth
you